I dreamed a dream ozawa come on
Hugh Jackman treated hollywood's night
under the stars to a medley of limas
classics for the motion picture
television funds 95th anniversary
I think this organization is one of the
great examples of the spirit of this
community of the entertainment industry
and of course you know I'm thrilled that
people are getting to know how our
community really looks after everybody
where are you at with Wolverine have you
finished eating so I just saw Jim mangle
today he's editing away and finishing
down I'm very very excited about it
there's gonna be some stuff coming out
in the next week or so that's all I'll
say I'm really trying to I'm not good
I'm the kind of person who tells
everybody everything basically it's
gonna be very different a very different
in tone and hopefully different too
which is a good thing easy for me to
play the greatest showman on earth we're
also very excited about what was the
status of that project I know you just
cast Rebecca Ferguson with good zac
efron the greatest chef exact by the way
he is phenomenal funny is that guy we
just did the table read two days ago so
funny zendaya
my daughter is beside herself
I've never been called before but now
I'm working with zendaya are you
bringing are you gonna bring her to the
table read her bring her on set and meet
Sunday oh now that you guys are taking
me to be in it in some way so I will say
yeah I for the next at least four months
while I'm working on the greatest
showmen I have something to hold over
her like if you've done your homework
maybe you can come in but apart from
that she never listened to dangle that
carrot for the whole time understand yes
oh by the way Zen day you'll come into
our place for dinner if she does her
homework I forgot to mention it to you
you